[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT in the show we
try to make Arthur Morgan aka dirty
Artie the dirtiest scummiest meanest
biggest POS Butthead we can possibly
make him talkin to every person who the
hell do you think you are smoking drunk
scold that dog no I can't do it
there exists nothing partner would you
like to play a game oh you like bossing
my friend huh go can't wait so again
Jake I took the time do you think I
should just follow this and repeat
without the rinse oho jump on my horse
[Laughter]
my turn I'm fine I'm fine
hell yeah this is our morning ritual now
if it's not it we're just dying if that
is it oh I looked away for a second oh I
hope that's wrong yeah yeah yep kill oh
it says kill we have some friends out
today was that kill I think I heard
[Laughter]
you're having a bad day petty
know how to run a good business be tough
be smart
and now his brains are all over the desk
counter oh my god
wow we have really racked up the body
count look Jeremiah kidney beans it's
the pig man again isn't it oh god man
where's the trouble he's turning away
I'm sorry
pig man oh no he's down there
I'm raccoon man we're meant to bring
peace to the city what have you become
punch it a white ray - Dale yeah that's
a maggot right there
I call this dirty Artie's horse
graveyard I got dirty
we got magnet one Oh maggot - Man three
magnet for and and Steve Oh
like say a few words to my horses oh oh
oh wait make me giddy
[Music]
oh stop drop and roll in jail Oh donkey
[Music]
what are you doing you think you just
sleep on the job oh damn
that's an alligator fetch boy well well
Jake we better we better get ourselves
back on the right track
ouch
hey can I use your camera save that for
later
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the confidence in this dance is
mesmerizing this guy don't look at him
don't look at those
[Music]